all right jake
jake uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally huntington beach
california
orange county orange county yeah and
tell me about your family he had mom and
dad yeah i had mom and dad um one sister
um they got divorced when i was about
12.
but it was always kind of like
they were divorced but living in the
same house so
it was kind of like a relief almost when
they got divorced
how would you describe your childhood in
general
dysfunctional
um
i was
more
i had anger issues as a kid i feel like
and i have adhd depression
bipolar disorder
a few different things so
growing up wasn't easy and
especially at school it wasn't easy
because i'd always be getting in trouble
for trying to talk too much or
bully if you're trying to talk too much
um is that the adhd yeah yeah and then
when i got put on meds
um
it made me just focus but like
apparently like it made me a zombie i
don't remember much but um
they didn't like me on meds much either
because
that was bad
so
it took me off that
then i got put on the
painkillers for having my leg broken so
you broke your leg skateboarding broke
my leg um motocross racing what
aggression yeah and then
after the painkillers
it's funny like i i didn't even start
doing them automatically like i saw it
on dr house that he popped them i was
like oh i have that in my cabinet
and i just like
popped two first time i got kind of sick
i was like
i don't know if i like this but at the
same time it was like
it was like
you know
a release like i stopped feeling
so much pain for a little bit i guess
and that's why i kept
continuing to use
went through that supply pretty quick
hundred bottle
um
sorry just trying to buy from people at
school but
that stopped working because people were
out
so
um i just kept they're selling those at
your high school oh yeah every joke you
could want
um i resorted to stealing
opiates for a long time actually i stole
um
a little pint from one of my friends
so
that's sad
um
this is a real
only a few people know about this one i
stole
uh
oxy from my aunt with cancer
so
some shows you where drugs can take you
um
i started doing a little bit better when
i got a girlfriend around 16.
um
for about a year or so i was working
just smoking weed that was it
um but things started getting toxic with
her
like
if i would be at work she would just
be trying to start fights with me while
i was at work for like whatever reason
she had
um
[Music]
what was it
it's one of the worst mental disorders i
forgot what it's called um
it's not borderline personality yeah
borderline personality disorder she has
that and um
if you don't know that's very hard to
live with she lived at my house so
fighting was constant
it's how i lost the tip of my finger
um
got slammed in a door when she was
screaming at me and i kept trying to run
away like to close his door and
she just kept slamming it open and
i tried to push it and she slammed it
and
it was on the ground and i was just like
holy [ __ ] like
my fingertips just on the ground like it
was kind of a surreal moment
and that was one of the first moments
where i realized like this relationship
is so not okay
and uh i went to the hospital my dad
took me she didn't come with me
so
um yeah
and it's funny because as soon as i saw
in the the johnny depp trial that he
lost his fingertip the same one on the
same hand and i was like that's so crazy
what a coincidence but not a good
coincidence
he and she actually had the same mental
disorder that amber heard had so
yeah interesting
so eventually this led to
street drugs oh yeah um
yeah well as things got worse
um well one time
uh i got a bunch of molly and
all of my friends we were rolling at the
skate park
and
the cops come they search everyone
luckily it was in my backpack
but everyone was on drugs and like i
didn't know how they didn't notice but
i got to go home and like i just raced
home and then
that night i went home and did like all
the molly and if you don't know what
happens after that
it's like the worst come down
in your life like you feel like you just
want to kill yourself like no serotonin
in your brain at all
and after that
um instead of just picking up weed like
i normally would i just got coke and
then i based on coke for a week
and then after that that come down
adding on to the other come down was
like
i couldn't handle it
i went and got some xanax bars from the
skate park
came home popped
three
the next morning
i
i
if you don't know what bar rage is i got
into bar rage i woke up and i was just
really mad and i started just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and
cops came and i got arrested for
six months
so that was the longest time i've ever
been sober
was that stint being in jail yeah
juvenile hall actually i turned 18 in in
juvenile hall see
oh
um that was a weird birthday
um
but honestly i wouldn't change it i
would still have gone because i feel
like it it made me a better person it
made me re-evaluate some things um
even though i came out and i started to
use again while i was in i i was like
working out instead of using drugs to
you know
fight those demons or whatever
and that was helping a lot i came out a
lot bigger than i went in because i was
bingeing on coke and stuff so i came in
i was skinny i went came out like pretty
good healthy
not much else to do in there yeah
exactly so said workout
so yeah um after i got out uh
i wanted to be sober but
like
everyone that i knew was smoking weed
and they were like oh dude you can just
smoke weed like you can just smoke weed
and like i kept telling them i don't
think i can i really don't think i can
just smoke weed but eventually i just i
gave in started smoking weed again
and that same day that i started smoking
weed
um
it just all it went all crazy um i
started drinking alcohol i popped some
clotting pan i got in a car crash
um at the beach i
i backed into some guy's car
and it was like smashed smashed in i was
i was so scared i heard him or something
and i got out and like
i was just like very intoxicated but i
dealt with it somehow still and like i
decided to drive home and like i felt so
bad i was like what the [ __ ] can i do
other than just giving my information
like
and that was like
you i would say it's a wake-up call but
it didn't wake me up i kept doing it so
um
it kept getting worse from that point um
a little bit after that my grandpa
passed away and i had to watch him pass
away we went to texas and um
for two weeks
watched him fade away in front of us
and i was
really
weird
um
and
to try to deal with that um
i popped like or i i tried to buy some
xanax to bring so i could deal with it
better when i was out there
and um i ended up
taking all the xanax at night all 10 and
i drove to my friend's house
and i don't remember driving there or
all i remember is stumbling in the door
and no one's saying a word to me
everyone was just staring at me like
what the [ __ ] how did like
what the [ __ ] going on like and i was
just pissed off that no one said
anything to me so i just got up and left
again somehow i drove home
didn't get a car crash
i don't know how many times i've driven
home and i don't remember a thing about
it and i just somehow woke up in my bed
and my car's outside
sometimes it was parked pretty [ __ ] up
but
i didn't kill anyone
luckily
um
so after my grandpa died i started using
heroin that was the first time i used
heroin
um
i went to his funeral on heroin
i don't know how much my family knew
about it but my ex said that they
probably all knew it was pretty obvious
she said
and um
yeah i came back um
i started to use fentanyl for the first
time i was at 17 and um
i only use it for about a week and i was
in the living room talking and i guess i
nodded out in front of my whole family
just like
and then i woke up with like my dad
shouting at me like what the [ __ ] are
you on like what the [ __ ] in like he
didn't let it go he was like
if you don't stop this
you're out that you're out of the house
you're out of the house if you don't
stop it and
um
i stopped i went through the withdrawals
um i used kratom my ex helped me through
it the whole time
and then um
the sad thing is i didn't stay sober i
just hopped onto adderall because i
started going to college as a way to
like he was my dad was like
either get a job or go to school you got
to do something now that you're off
heroin again you can't just be sitting
in my house so
i started to go to college again
um
originally i was just taking adderall
because i have adhd and i literally
cannot focus i tried to go a few days
and i could not focus at all
and um
it was sad i i really wanted to be able
to focus but like it's just not i don't
have the ability to and so i try to
start taking adderall and i was able to
focus i was able to retain the
information
it was working like i was so happy that
this first time like i didn't really
remember taking it as a kid much but
taking it
starting again it was like
i can actually like
i could sit and do things i'm motivated
i haven't been able to do any of this my
whole life
so
i loved it and
the adderall dealer moved away and i was
everyone always said like it's so close
to math like methanol are the same thing
they're not the same thing
but
i started doing math and it got a lot
worse
it went from me taking adderall to to
make clothes and do homework and stuff
for college to
me doing math and playing video games
all day long
and or me doing meth in
doing [ __ ] i shouldn't be doing behind
my girlfriend's back not cheating but
stuff i shouldn't be doing um
that was one of the
main things in our relationship that
[ __ ] it up was um
me using math
um it was already a bad relationship but
the math made everything so much worse
because when she would be angry
instead of me being calm and trying to
deal with her being upset i would also
be extremely angry and i wouldn't be
able to control it so
she would start throwing blows and i
would just try to be pushing her out of
the room and like
it was just it was not good like my dad
had to physically like escort her out of
my house multiple times
um she broke down my door one time and
left a scar on my face like broke it
down and it hit my face and left a scar
she tried to kill herself in my bed
almost successfully she stole my bars
popped 10 of those
walked down to the
walked down to the liquor store stole
some hennessy um down that
and i come in
to my room and she's just like
didn't look like she was alive and i
started like pushing on and like she
wasn't breathing
that was terrifying um i was tripping on
that i was tripping actually that day um
i was on 2cb and
snapped me out of it real quick i got
sober real quick i just
started to like like push on her chest
like i don't have to do cpr but i tried
and
um
i started to give her mouse to mouth and
the mouth-to-mouth worked somehow she
just started to breathe again and i was
like like [ __ ] sobbing i was just
sobbing i was like no you can't you
can't die you cannot die you cannot die
like i'm not letting it happen
whatever like it's not happening like
sorry it's not happening and like i'm
nurtured back to health i made her throw
everything up like you know what the
[ __ ] up part was it was her dad's
birthday and i was trying to call an
ambulance and she was just begging me
like don't call an ambulance my dad's
birthday he'll [ __ ] everything up for me
and like i feel like a piece of [ __ ]
because i didn't call an ambulance but
like at the same time like i'm thinking
i'm trying to help her but it really
wasn't helping her
and uh
of course my family wasn't there for
that whole entire thing so no one was
there to stop anything
um
that was traumatizing
so where are you at today where am i at
today what are you doing i mean are you
still using yeah um
i was
actually
it's funny because i keep i keep trying
to quit
you know it's not easy quitting fentanyl
but um i kept messing up going on my
methadone clinic and i would like skip a
few days and i'd have to restart the
dose or whatever and
in two or three days my dose should be
back up to what it should be and
i'm gonna try to quit again in like two
to three days and i
really hope this time it works because
the dose should be at the right point so
but yeah
i am still using fentanyl um i'm not
using method anymore i quit that a long
time ago
fentanyl is just about the only drug i
do except for xanax sometimes to because
i have pretty bad anxiety
insomnia is there downside to taking the
adderall
oh
yeah
one thing it does is make you very
sexually devious
like
you do you do things you would never do
and and everyone can act like they don't
but it's an open known thing for for
adderall and math that it it makes you
very like you do some pretty messed up
[ __ ] um
you get angry very easily very very
easily um and you can't like stop being
angry like you just storm around the
house [ __ ] mad like
there's lots of downsides to adderall i
don't think the upsides are worth it
because i'm gonna i'm going back to
college and i'm not taking adderall i'm
never gonna take that stuff again it's
not worth the risk in my opinion
i mean amongst your peers
like when you're in high school or back
in in huntington beach are there a lot
of kids that are in a similar situation
with drugs as you
no really actually no i was one of the
few in my school um
i dropped out like sophomore year um
i got my ged but
you know um
it's good to hear i didn't really know
many people to be honest like i had a
very small group of friends um
the worst they did was maybe like xanax
they didn't
get close to what i did um
and after high school everyone i knew
kind of started just like drifting away
um
i just one
really good friend still and
we were like starting a brand together
because i'm into fashion if you
couldn't tell it's one of the few things
that i still have during my addiction
and um
we were doing a brand together and
like i had a few of things that i had
in this collection i was going to make
but it was not released yet and he just
went and took everything and released it
on his own brand and like did give me
credit didn't ask me anything so that
was the end of that friendship
and i was like the last friend i had
where and then i had like no friends and
then
my ex was like all i had for a long time
and then after
i cluttered like
doing [ __ ] behind my back multiple times
i finally just like
i thought like if she's not gonna stop
and it's it's not gonna stop hurting me
i have to make the decision to make her
stop hurting me so
i did that and then after that is when i
started to really use that null um
right after that breakup
that's the first time that i used
fentanyl in a few years um that's how it
started this this current addiction
was that break up
it took the pain away completely 100
took the pain away
so it was helpful at first um for
maybe like a month
and then i realized when i don't have it
i go to severe withdrawals and it was
terrifying to realize that because i
didn't have it one time and
i didn't know how bad it was gonna get
and i it got so bad and
withdrawals are the worst part about it
i'd say
it's really
i wouldn't wish it on anyone
like i just had covid and that's the
sickest i've ever been and i would
prefer that to withdrawals any day
for sure
what are you afraid of now
i'm afraid of
not being who i feel like i could be
i'm afraid of wasting my potential
because i feel like i know i have a lot
of potential are there things you'd like
to do with your life yeah um fashion
like i make clothes
um photography
like graphic design and i've been told
by many people i'm very good at it like
people buy my clothes sometimes like
i'm not ashamed or i'm not like afraid
to say like i know i'm very good at
fashion
but um
it yeah i know during the this addiction
it has kind of taken that away to an
extent though um
i'm not really making clothes anymore
i'm just buying them
so that's really something that i want
to start again but at the same time it's
like
the only time i was able to do that
really like
well was when i was on math and it's
like i don't want to go back to that
just to make clothes so it's a really
weird predicament
like
it's hard to
do anything without
the stimulant when you have adhd it's
just really hard
so
what's your biggest regret
that's a really big question
i'd say
smoking weed after i got
out of jail you feel like weed's a
gateway
for me i don't think it's the gateway
for everyone but i think when i do any
drugs
it's it just goes all out like
so yeah i feel like that's if i i really
feel like if i chose not to charge
smoking weed i would be completely cool
right now
i think i would have been able to deal
with everything in a different way i
think i would have learned how to i
would have worked out at home like i did
and i wouldn't be in the mess i am now
like
it's just
it's crazy how much money i've spent on
this drug like it's the most money i've
ever spent in my life
and it just goes to waste just so i can
feel normal like i don't get high
anymore i just feel normal
that's what sucks like
i don't
get any relief i just
well i get relief from feeling super
shitty but i don't feel good ever so
jake what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
21 years
when you have a good thing
don't
try to don't don't resort back to your
old ways and make a mistake because
you're on this new path and
you could do so much
and if you know that
something
will bring you back to your old ways you
need to stay away from it
all right jake thank you so much for
sharing your story
i appreciate you lots of luck in your
future
thank you
you